اين تحدث الزلازل في العالم ما اقوى
الزلازل التي حدثت في القرن الماضي وايها
الاكثر ضررا على البشر من حيث الخسائر
البشريه والمعديه نجيب عن هذه الاسئله في
عرض يبسطها بشكل كبير هذه هي الزلازل التي
حصلت خلال نحو قرن من الزمان بحسب قوتها
بمجرد النظر الى الصوره نستطيع ملاحظه
معلومتين رئيسيتين تحدث الزلازل غالبا عند
اطراف القارات والتقائها ببعض المسطحات
المائيه لاحظوا مثلا التقاط التقاء المحيط
الهادئ بشرق اسيا او بغرب الامريكيتين
الملاحظه الثانيه هي اننا كلما دخلنا الى
وسط اليابسه في القارات قلت احتماليه
الزلازل كما نلاحظ هنا في اوراسيا وفي
افريقيا وايضا في وسط وشرق الامريكيتين
طبعا يرتبط هذا بمصطلح نسمعه كثيرا هذه
الايام هو الصفائح
التكتونيه وهي ببساطه قشره الارض العلويه
تمت سبع صفائح رئيسيه كما ترون من خلفي في
الخريطه اكبرها صفيحه المحيط الهادي من
الجانبين طبعا ثم امريكا الشماليه ثم
اوراسيا وكما لاحظنا تقع الزلازل على نقاط
التقاء هذه الصفائح الان نتابع اقوى
الزلازل في العالم الدوائر الحمراء التي
تشاهدونها هي لزلازل تجاوزت قوتها ثمانيه
درجات على مقياس ريختر بينما السوداء
الكبيره هي لزلازل تجاوزت تسعه درجات
وطبعا اكبرها هو زلزال تشيلي عام 1960
والذي وصل تقريبا الى 9.5 ثم زلزال الاسكا
عام 64
9.2 زلزال مطره في اندونيسيا
عام 2004 توهكو في اليابان وطبعا كل هذه
الزلازل تجاوزت تسعه درجات كما نلاحظ لكن
الزلزال الاكبر لا يعني انه الاكثر ضررا
اذ يرتبط هذا بالكثافه السكانيه في موقع
الزلزال زلزال تانشان في الصين والذي قدر
عدد ضحاياه كما تشاهدون ب 300 الف كان
الاكثر ضررا بالبشر الثاني في الصين ايضا
زلزال هايوان برقم ضحايا مقارب ثم سومطره
بما يزيد علم 200 الف قتيل اعلى الزلازل
كلفه كما تلاحظون في هذه القائمه كانت في
اليابان في زنزالي توهكو وهانشين العظيم
وطبعا هذا الاختلاف لان الخسائر البشريه
تختلف عن الخسائر الماديه التي ترتبط عاده
بطبيعه البنيه التحتيه للمنطقه التي
يصيبها الزلزال